meiosis is a central event in the lives
of most eukaryotes including humans
gametes are produced with half the
number of chromosomes of their parent
cells
this allows them to fuse and form a
genetically unique diploid embryo that
grows into an adult
mitosis results in two daughter cells
that each has the same number and kind
of chromosomes as the parent nucleus
this is typical of ordinary tissue
growth and repair
in a mitosis chromosome cohesion exists
along the entire length of the
chromosome between centromeres and along
chromosome arms
sister kinetochores lie back to back and
face in opposite directions
during mitosis chromosome cohesion is
gradually lost over the entire length of
the chromosome as sister chromatids
separate and move to opposite poles in
anaphase
in meiosis one two pairs of sister
chromatids are linked together to form
by valence they're held together as a
result of sister chromatid cohesion
along chromosome arms and the presence
of one or more crossovers between the
two homologous chromosomes
sister kinetochores in each bivalent are
seemingly fused together and sister
chromatids appear to share a single
fused kinetochore
in anaphase 1 cohesion between sister
chromatid arms is gradually released but
cohesion between the centromeres of
sister chromatids is maintained
as a result pairs of sister chromatids
separate from one another and move to
each spindle pole
in meiosis ii chromosomes attach to the
spindle differently with changes in
chromosome structure and chromatids are
distributed with one to each future
gamete
when the chromosome attaches to the
spindle a single kinetochore is
associated with each sister chromatid
and the kinetochores separate
throughout metaphase ii centromere
cohesion is retained
in anaphase ii centromere cohesion is
released causing sister chromatids to
separate and move into splitting
daughter cells
this results in four haploid meiotic
products that can become gametes
kinetochore arrangement and chromosome
cohesion are key changes in chromosome
structure in meiosis
therefore changes in chromosome
structure in meiosis 1 and 2 are
responsible for the correct reduction of
the number of chromosomes in the process
of meiosis